snoop dogg is joining this season as a
mega mentor i
love snoop dogg he loves you back
well now we also know that ariana grande
will replace nick jonas next season
my daughter is very upset as am i
because nick told
everyone who's gonna be on the show
forever where are you now nick
where are you now how do you think that
they landed a mega pop star like that
it's probably because they gave her some
money that's why i'm here today
you're not getting paid wait huh
please welcome to ariana grande did the
voice make it rain on ariana
a new report says she's getting a grande
paycheck
to the tune of 20 to 25 million dollars
for just one season
ari has 10 times more insta followers
than the other three coaches combined
and there's precedent for that kind of
massive payout
i got paid yeah katy perry celebrated
reports she got 25 mill to do idol
more than like pretty much any guy
that's been on that show
ari's payday would also trounce her male
colleagues
blake and john reportedly pull in 13
million each a season
but shelton's rich in friends blake is
like snoop dogg
we would have been in school together we
both would have been getting suspended
once we started hanging out and doing
our thing it was like man y'all act like
y'all been knowing each other for 20 30
years
it's the one and only beagle double g
snoop makes his mega mentor debut the
day before his favorite holiday 4
20 but will the rap icons budding
bromance produce a new collab
get a bunch of his favorite stuff to
drink and get a bunch of my favorite
stuff to do
and hello i feel like you're setting us
up it may happen man i mean i wouldn't
doubt i think blake is in l.a now his
wife is from orange county so i'm pretty
sure they relocating this way
you just called gwen blake's wife do you
know something we don't know that's his
fiancee
[Music]
right